Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking
with Jesse Singer, who is a journalist and
also author of the book There Are No Accidents
The Deadly Rise of Injury and Disaster Who
Profits and Pay and Who Pays the Price.
Jesse, great to have you on.
I really appreciate it.
Speaker 6: Thank you so much for having me,
David.
Speaker 1: So, you know, in the context of
these, I'll start with something kind of micro
and then we'll go from there.
There's often these stories of, Oh, there
was an accident with a gun.
Someone was shot.
It was an accident.
A guy accidentally shot his daughter while
cleaning the gun or something like this.
And we often will talk about on the show where.
Okay, yes, we sort of understand socially
what the term accident means under the law.
This is often called the negligent discharge
of a firearm.
And sometimes it is something that people
are charged with and it's considered a crime,
at least in theory.
But the term accident sometimes puts like
a very particular spin, as it may be on our
understanding of sort of like what happened.
You talk about this at the corporate and the
industrial and other levels.
Talk a little bit about what does it mean
for something to be an accident in the context
of law and our understanding of what took
place to just kind of get us into the discussion.
Speaker 6: Yeah.
I mean, it's a really tricky term in that
sense because it means so many different things
to so many different people.
And then has this specific legal definition
of the line between intentional violence and
maybe an act of God.
You know, someone who dies during a hurricane,
for example, totally out of our control.
And it is a way of, I found in the book absolving
certain people when things go wrong and punishing
others, you know.
And so we see really different outcomes depending
on who's shot in the case of an accidental
discharge, you know, who the victim is and
who's gone.
It was and whether or not we want to put blame
on them as a society.
And this even breaks down to the smallest
levels.
Like if you look at people being killed by
drivers and like jaywalking crashes.
Yes.
Or like drunk, drunk driving crashes in particular
where someone is, you know, struck by a driver.
The race of the victim correlates with sentence
length so that if the person struck by a drunk
crossing the street by a drunk driver is black,
the sentence length of the driver is significantly
lower.
So there isn't an area of accidental, so called
accidental death where, you know, we're not
seeing huge variations in how the term is
understood to to, you know, kind of equate
for different punishments.
And then since so many of these things are
not individual acts of human error, but really
predictable, preventable, systemic causes,
we see the least culpability when it comes
to the actual corporate perpetrators of these
crimes, you know, and like how.
The make and model of a gun and the design
of a gun and the way that the gun has not
been regulated is actually the real problem
here, rather than whether or not it went off
when you were cleaning it.
Speaker 1: You know, there's this book I read
a few months ago.
I think it must be about 20 years old now.
It's called normal accidents by a guy named
Charles Perot, I think is the pronunciation
of his last name.
And in the book, he talks about a lot of different
areas.
He talks about aircraft accidents.
He talks about nuclear heat, all these different
areas.
And he kind of distinguishes what we might
call like systemic accidents, which are, in
a sense, predictable, where we might say,
here is a system.
Here are the tolerances.
Here are the ways the system can fail.
And we can sort of make a prediction as to
how common these things will be.
And it's not going to be zero.
Almost certainly it's not going to be zero.
And one of the really interesting things he
writes about in the book is that as you add
mechanisms to try to make a system more safe,
the added complexity and the fact that you
now have systems interacting can actually
keep the odds of an accident, so-called roughly
the same, or sometimes even even kind of increase
them.
We know that to some degree, these accidents
are predictable in systems because actuaries
in insurance, part of their job is to sort
of like put a monetary value and a number
on how likely are some of these things to
happen.
On the on the issue of predictability and
preventable when it comes to industrial type
stuff.
We often will learn after the fact that industry
knew about a lot of these risks very specifically,
and they either minimized it, covered it up,
whatever the case may be.
What are the kind of counter pressures that
the public can sort of exert or the tools
that exist not after the fact to do a class
action lawsuit or a mass tort?
But in the lead up to these systems, sometimes
failing and what as you write about also are
predictable ways.
Speaker 6: Absolutely.
Yeah.
Perils like kind of one of the classics of
this field who really, like, gave us a framework
for understanding.
And one of the things I try to do in the book
is take Pedro's basic ideas, this normal accident
theory, and by which he didn't mean normal
as in common, but but predictable.
Yes, the inevitable consequence of our systems.
And he meant that an accident is a thing that
exists in four walls, a nuclear power plant,
an oil tanker, this contained thing.
But something I try to do is blow out that
theory to look at the much larger systems
we have that correlate directly to accidents.
And that's income inequality, that's racism,
that's corporate power and a lack of union
power.
Because we talk about these things as random.
And if it was true, then an injury related
death would be randomly distributed across
the country.
But it isn't true.
People of color, people living in poverty
are most at risk.
And what we see is that most people who die
in accidents don't die in Charles Perot's
accidents, a nuclear meltdown right now, ones
and twos every day on our roads, in our homes
and in our workplaces.
And so to answer like what the solution is
at the core of it is that these accidents
where people of color and people living in
poverty are most at risk, are accidents where
policy and infrastructure make the difference
between life and death.
So the safety of our roads, homes, the safety
of our roads, the safety of our workplaces,
and that's where we see these huge disparities
in accidental deaths.
So to name one, black people die in house
fires at twice the rate of white people.
Indigenous people are struck by cars at twice
the rate of white people.
So these aren't matters of individual error.
These are matters of different conditions
at different people are facing whether or
not your apartment is a fire trap and whether
or not your government is regulating your
apartment and holding your landlord to account.
And so the big picture answer is that, you
know, regulating corporate power and forcing
policy to protect everyone universally, primarily
through government regulation and access to
the social safety net, will reduce the way
that risk is currently unequally distributed
across the US.
Speaker 1: It seems there's also sort of like
a psychological component, like if we think
about drug overdoses as an example.
Recently at his rallies, Donald Trump has
been to much praise from the audience talking
about we should do the death penalty for drug
dealers.
They do it in China, a quick trial, 100% conviction
rate, you know, all sorts of authoritarian
dystopian nightmares.
But the crowd loves it and they cheer.
And there is something about when there is
an individual.
Here's the guy on the corner who gave me the
drugs versus here's a pharmaceutical company
that uses sales reps to encourage the overprescription,
which then you get from a doctor filled by
a pharmacist.
The personal blame seems much easier psychologically
when it's the guy on the corner to some degree,
and that's probably much to the delight of
the big pharma companies and their lobbyists.
Right.
Like that's bite.
That's a feature for them.
Speaker 6: Yeah, absolutely.
And I think you often see, you know, today
from pharma companies, but throughout the
history of accidental death, whenever there's
a rise in one specific type of accidental
death, you see corporations pushing these
bad people stories.
Right.
And so, you know, you see it directly.
I'm going to quote one of the Purdue pharma
leaders who was like, the problem here early
in the opioid epidemic is the criminal addicts,
the abusers.
They're the problem, not how we're marketing.
An addictive drug is not addictive, but these
individuals, and that is deeply comforting
for us as people.
We are comforted and feel permitted to move
on from what seems like random tragedy when
we can find a bad guy because it's a way for
us all to say.
I wouldn't make those decisions.
I'm not like that person that that person
who died, that person who hurt someone.
I'm nothing like them because they're bad.
And when we define them as bad, we can see
ourselves as good as a smarter as someone
who will do a little better under the same
circumstances.
And this ranges from accidental death, where
we really do see a stigmatized bad person,
like a person who's addicted to drugs.
Yeah.
But also when, you know, on the little ones,
like a traffic crash or, you know, a fire
where a kid was playing with matches, finding
the bad person, you know, blaming the parent,
blaming the jaywalking pedestrian is a way
for us all to say, it can't happen to me.
I make better decisions.
And we see throughout the history of accidental
death, even all the way back to the Industrial
Revolution, you know, when workers were dying
in untold numbers in factories and coal mines.
We see industrialists pushing this idea of
the accident prone worker and this caricature
and stereotype of a drunk immigrant who doesn't
speak English.
Sloppy worker.
That was really the cause of this massive
accidental death toll, when in fact it was
actually that the factories and the coal mines
were incredibly dangerous.
And we know this because when we start to
regulate those factories and coal mines, accidental
death on the job plummets.
Speaker 1: Yes.
So speaking of that, I mean, I think it's
not at all a one, but it's an all of the above
for me, not a one of these things.
We have ways in which regulation can make
things safer, whatever it is.
Those things we're talking about are there's
also those who say to different degrees, technology
is going to dramatically improve these things
as we learn more about how to design roads,
self-driving cars, you know, you have all
of these ideas that at some point technology
is going to make a lot of things much safer.
Technology in factories, that is going to
reduce injury, for example.
The counter to that seems to be that the new
technology allows the limits to be pushed
for profit again.
So like now you have sort of like the same
amount of safety, but there's more profit
and more productivity.
And so you have to know kind of how to counterbalance
that.
But to what degree is it fair to believe that
technology will be a factor in making the
world safer?
Speaker 6: You know, so this is this is an
old story.
And there's always been huge advances in technology
that have reduced the accidental death toll.
But only under one condition, which is when
they are regulated.
Hmm.
And so if you look at technology like seatbelts,
airbags, collapsible steering column, these
were in the car.
Huge advances in safety, but only once they
were regulated into every American automobile.
And when they're not, when you have government
regulatory agencies that are afraid to regulate,
like Nissan is today, we get into a situation
where rich people survive and poor people
die.
So like fully autonomous driverless cars are
a way off.
But there's a wealth of life saving technology
that already exists, is tested and proven,
automatic emergency braking, intelligent assist,
speed governors that are regulated in other
countries where accidental death is far lower.
But we don't mandate them here.
Cars are under-regulated, so only the rich
are protected.
The rich pay for features that could say everyone
save everyone's life if the government forced
it.
You know, and we see the same thing, you know,
as far back as the Industrial Revolution,
you know, there were technologies, a few companies
were putting them forth, but the overall death
rates weren't falling because the government
wasn't forcing corporations to account.
And when that happened, we saw results.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to talk about.
Inevitably, one could imagine this kind of
caricature of the overregulated nanny state,
where we take everything you and I are talking
about to the absolute extreme.
And, you know, science fiction movies are
made about it and it's all very, very scary.
And to some degree, I'm like sort of joking
about it.
But also I think even people who are in favor
of a stronger regulatory infrastructure would
concede that there's some limit at which we
say, Well, here are some choices we simply
allow people to make, but we want to limit
the collateral damage that might be associated
with those choices.
So it's really a choice that only affects
the person making the decision.
How do we start to think about where on the
slider we sort of put that pin between the
idea of freedom and safety, or do you think
that that is not even a valid spectrum for
discussion?
Speaker 6: I think it is a notably new spectrum
to discussion, and I think we spend a little
too much time on it.
Just thinking about more than 200,000 people
every year in the US that are dying completely
preventable deaths and those numbers are infinitely
lower.
In other wealthy countries, the rate of accidental
death is so much higher here because we have
this rhetorical conversation about freedom.
But when it comes down to it, I think the
nanny state is wonderful if you don't want
to die an early death.
I mean, what's a nanny?
It's someone that rich people pay to protect
their children from death.
We should all have that up.
Americans will respond to what our leaders
promote.
This country did not start to reject the protections
of a benevolent government on its own.
It's a product of corporate propaganda sold
through the mouthpiece of anti-government,
anti-regulatory presidents, and that's been
happening for decades.
I don't think Americans want to die horrible,
painful early deaths in the name of freedom.
We just need politicians brave enough to protect
people and to tell a better story than this
anti-government, anti-regulatory propaganda
that we've been sold.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Crying about a nanny state often is a way
to kind of invalidate conversations about
just reasonable regulations that that should
exist.
It's sort of a way to kind of clamp down on
debates.
It's kind of similar to.
I'm offended, I'm afraid.
Well, okay, the conversation's over then.
I guess it's a similar cudgel in a sense.
Speaker 6: Yeah, absolutely.
And it leaves us in this place where people
die incredibly preventable deaths every day
in ones and twos.
And we all tell a story about personal responsibility
and the fact that maybe they were bad people,
even though they are simply protectable.
We're not going to fix human error.
We're not going to make people perfect.
But there are so many ways we could protect
them from harm that we are disregarding for
a conversation about freedom in the nanny
state and the need for personal responsibility.
Speaker 1: Just the last thing lowest hanging
fruit in terms of preventable death that could
be improved relatively simply or easily.
We know what to do.
What are the areas that people may or may
not know about?
Where the numbers are high and could be lowered
dramatically?
Speaker 6: It's true in every area of accidental
death by simply empowering our regulatory
agencies so people are better protected and
reviving the social safety net so people can
afford to better protect themselves, you know,
not drive an old car, take the most dangerous
job, live in a fire trap apartment.
And because accidental death is so broad,
there are a million ways to do it in your
community.
You can advocate for traffic calming and public
transit expansions because you're far less
likely to die or to kill someone if you're
riding the bus than you are.
If you're in your own car, you can fight for
safe injection sites and the free distribution
of naloxone, which directly, dramatically
reduces accidental overdose deaths.
Pushing for ADA accessibility accessibility
like ramps and grab bars in your workplace
and in your apartment building is going to
reduce accidental death, making sure fire
safety regulations are on the books and enforced
sprinklers, self-closing doors, all this stuff.
It doesn't reduce the likelihood of you making
a mistake or a kid playing with fire or someone
not being a distracted driver just reduces
the likelihood that it's going to kill anyone.
It just protects people.
Speaker 1: We have been talking with Jesse
Singer, who is a journalist and also author
of the book There Are No Accidents The Deadly
Rise of Injury and Disaster Who Profits and
Who Pays the Price.
Jesse, really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 6: Thanks so much for having me, David.